each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay welcome to session five
of six we're getting there the
penultimate session um for those of you
who want there's a signup shooting back
to try to get the prize for those who
attend all sessions or I think maybe
it'll be five out of six sessions it's
not up to me to decide that we'll say um
but um we'll have uh some some
interesting things to talk about today
so first of all just review last time we
uh spent some time talking about
primality testing um and then um
elliptic curves and Lattis Bas systems I
just want to see if there are any
lingering questions on this before we
get going
okay um by the way um one of our own
experts who was um one of the plants in
the room when I gave this talk uh Craig
Costello is going to be giving a real
talk on otic curve crypto systems and
Lattis space crypto systems um the
middle of next month I think it's June
11th so if you want to see a real
research level talk on that you know can
come um or you sign up for the MSR
lecture alias if if you haven't already
or just ask me and I'll I'll give you
the details on when that is okay so
today we get to talk about as said in
the title attacks vulnerabilities and
practical
considerations and given where we are
and given you know what's current I have
no choice as much as I would like to do
otherwise but to start
there okay but I'm not going to really
say a lot here there isn't a lot to say
really it's kind of a run-of-the-mill
buffer overrun or bounds checking sort
of problem you this is the sort of thing
that happens a lot it's good practice
and you know um good you know
maintaining good quality of code it's
not really a crypto issue or even a
general security issue in any sense the
issue here was it happened in some
pretty critical security code op SSL and
that caused it to lead some catastrophic
in some people's words consequences
basically it's a buffer overrun that
said I'll allocate a very big buffer in
my query and just fill it with a small
amount of of stuff so you will return
filling the the buffer with whatever you
happen to have in memory and I get to
see what you happen to have in your
memory dear SSL server and what you
happen to have in memory is often key
material maybe your long-term keys
because you've been decrypting stuff
maybe just short-term user keys but lots
of Juicy stuff seems to be in this you
memory that you can just say oh please
give me a copy so I can look at it so
yeah be careful about bounce checking
please you know but this is you know
nothing new okay enough said about this
and unless anybody wants to harp on this
because I really don't want to I've been
hearing enough about this
lately yes that what are the things sdl
is supposed to take care of notice this
op SSL however op SSL creeps into our
stuff from time to time for a variety of
reasons but we we did pretty well in
avoiding this okay um we did we have
discussed some vulnerabilities in the
past so I'll just mention a few of them
here because this is the sort of theme
that we'll be talking about today we
talked about when we started talking
about stream ciphers and I think it was
the very first session um we talked
about the problem of reusing a stream
Cipher key and that it allows the entire
key stream to be discovered by an
attacker um if you just use the same key
twice it will generate the same key
stream and the key stream can then be
discovered and if other things were
coded with that stream those can easily
be be checked as well um stream ciphers
also have issues um if they are used
without Integrity checking if there's no
Integrity check then uh an attacker can
take a legitimate encryption of
something and tweak get bit by bit um
ways to make it mean something else and
still look legitimate if there is no
Integrity check so Integrity checking is
really important there and there's an
attack if you don't do it uh we also
talked about the digital signature
algorithm the SAA and what really bad
things can happen if you don't um use
enough Randomness if you don't generate
a new random value every time you sign
something um this was the thing that
happened with uh Sony and Playstation a
few years ago where they reused um
Randomness and reusing Randomness there
allows discovery of not just the
decryption of something but they're
long-term private key it's really bad
and this is actually something that that
happens a lot I want to sort of focus on
this a little bit this Randomness is a
key issue that has to be gotten right
when doing any kind of security in
cryptography in particular if you don't
have enough Randomness you don't have
enough entropy
then really really bad things happen and
it's really hard to get this right so
this happens a lot um you if if you
don't have enough then you know you
generate keys that are low entropy
people can guess the keys okay protocols
can fail because people can figure out
things that are supposed to be random
can um supposed to be unpredictable they
can be figured out not good so um a a
well-known instance of this I have to
mention is Debian um which open also was
op SSL by the way um just yet another op
SSL case um but this a few years ago um
the story of what happened here was they
were getting a lot of the entropy they
used in key Generation by taking an
uninitiated um buffer just here's some a
pile of memory that's been used for
other stuff we're not going to
initialize it in any way just take
what's there and you know use that to
get a lot of our Randomness a lot of our
entropy um a few years later after you
know somebody had put this in the code
somebody else went through with with
some code quality tools and found oh
here's this uninitialized memory being
used bad thing right we got to clean
that up you know set it all to zero
clean it up so that was
done it wasn't the only entropy being
used so this wasn't discovered
immediately but
this left about 16 bits of
entropy per
key now 16 bits is not very good so it
it affected lots of keys where low
entropy keys and could be discovered and
the particularly bad case of this was
RSA keys because what happened was there
were people who would you generate prime
a generate Prime B multiply them
together somebody else generates prime a
and generates Prime C multiply together
two you know different RSA keys we're
fine no problem and some was noticed
well they're different RSA keys but they
share a prime and therefore if you take
a greatest common divisor which is
easily computable between this key and
that key suddenly we've got the prime
suddenly I now can Factor your key and
you can Factor my key and worse yet
anybody can take our two keys and get a
get one of the prime factors and
therefore Factor both of them so not
good and in fact this has gone on
somewhat past de Debian so you know RSA
keys were a problem here but we've since
done some looking at sort of the
universe of RSA keys out in the world
the millions of certified RSA keys that
are you sitting in various places on the
internet and people have found that a
surprising number of them share common
primes or even are identical The
Identical ones maybe there's some other
excuse for you know the same key as
being used in two different places by
two different people okay maybe but but
you definitely shouldn't have you know
two keys that share a prime and that
happened surprisingly often much more
than anybody had expected uh We've
looked at this some some other other
groups have looked at the some um and
there are some very strange phenomena
there's one place where um I think um it
was discovered that there were basically
nine primes being used and all possible
combinations of those nine primes made
it into a key in one of the devices that
was you know used by this company so you
you know you have yeah this list of nine
primes and P3 and P6 yep that occurs
there and P3 and p8 that occurs there
yeah and everything that could go wrong
good go ahead I'm surprised I can't
intuitively figure out
why determining the the common
denominator would be easier than
factoring these large numbers oh um why
is that so much easier there's a bit of
magic that um I could show you in about
5 minutes um I don't have any slides on
this ready but uh it's actually very
it's it's pretty easy magic but there is
there is actually a very efficient
algorithm for computing greatest common
divisors greatest common factors so if I
take P * Q or let's say p * q1 and P *
Q2 and run the greatest common divisor
algorithm P pops out okay and it turns
turns out to be a very simple algorithm
um dates back to the time of uclid um um
and uh effectively what do is the the
intuition for it is if if I've got P
times something here and P time
something here and I subtract them their
difference is also P times
something it's also a multiple of P so
now I can subtract as many of these as I
want and as many of those and no matter
how many subtraction I do it's still a
multiple of p and I can just sort of
work it down so it's smaller and smaller
and smaller until I get down to just p
and nothing else and this turns out to
be a very simple thing to do by just you
know divide this by this take the
remainder and now to divide this by the
remainder and and just go through and
turns and it turns out it's in theory as
fast as multiplying A and B you can take
the gcd of A and B um in practice it's a
little bit slower but not that much
slower it it's really quick
mhm point this question I'm trying to
figure out when they're doing the
studies on RSA keys and common primes
how are they doing that we can't just go
out there and ask everyone hey give us
the primes of your keys No but we can
ask everybody to give us their their
their products their actual keys and
then we do the gcds okay which may not
come to an answer if they don't have
well it'll come out to one if they have
no common factor the the greatest common
factor greatest common diviser is one um
and and it turns out and that this I
won't go into because it is much harder
is doing the gcd of two things is
there's there's a fairly direct way of
doing it doing a common gcd of many
things there's also a really nice trick
out there so you can actually take these
many things and figure out if there are
any pairs that have common factors um
it's a little bit more work certainly
Beyond here but that's the trick that's
used to to make this happen um I I no
I'll I'll I'll move
on Corner me later for a story on this
if you want okay another kind of attack
I want to mention before you know the
I'm taking care of some of the small
ones first um length extension attacks
are something that that crops up a lot
and we have to be aware of and that's
because of how we normally do
authentication so we might have an
authenticated message M that looks like
you know a message that I send to my
bank that says please tell me my bank
account B and the way we have typically
been authenticating is with some sort of
a message authentication code so a
message authentication code could be as
simple as an Integrity check like this
there's a common key that we share I
hash that key together with the message
and you then get the
message you take the common key together
with the message and see if you get the
same Integrity check that I sent you and
since nobody else knows the key nobody
else can forge that message
so this actually works reasonably well
as far as it goes here however the way
hash functions normally work they don't
all have to work this way but they they
work typically by iterating over their
inputs and you just how however many
arguments they take you sort of work
through the first few hundred bytes and
the next 100 bytes and then just keep on
working through so what you can do is
add
something I don't have to know what h of
KM is in order to to take that and
extend it to get to H of KM M Prime so I
can compute an Integrity check that
works if I append M Prime from the
Integrity check that worked without the
M Prime and there are various versions
of this out in the world I'm I'm not
going to go through a lot of other
examples but just gives you a sense of a
kind of thing to be aware of okay
so now I want to get into a somewhat
deeper area yeah so just on that one
that only works if your integrity check
is not encrypted right um the Integrity
check in this case yes um the Integrity
check typically is not encrypted there's
actually a lot of work on how to best do
Integrity checks um or message
authentication codes I I'll term them
that way there's a lot of controversy
and a lot of debate over years over
three possible ways of dealing with um
with Max there are known as encrypt and
Mac encrypt then Mac and Mac then
encrypt and if you think about it it's
whether you um encrypt then Mac would be
uh well sort of encrypt and Mac would be
I encrypt something and I take a an
Integrity check on that something and
those two are separate fine it turns out
to be best of those three in most cases
to do encrypt then Mac which would be I
encrypt it and then I Mack the encrypted
value not the unencrypted value um in
this case we're not bothering with any
encryption so that that doesn't really
affect things so it would be okay here
and then Mac then encrypt um would would
be um you Mac it and then encrypt the
whole thing including the the mac and
there's lots of delicate things about um
this and and um I just saw literally a
couple days ago a new paper um
suggesting that the common wisdom of um
encrypt then Mac is not necessarily the
right thing to do in all cases um you
know we settled on Crypton Mac everybody
was happy and then
well sort of but in most cases it is the
right thing to do check check with with
us if you want to do anything
unusual okay
so RSA and attacks on RSA um so there
are a lot of issues with using RSA that
requires us to be careful first of all
RSA is a deterministic
algorithm right you take a value you
raise it to a power you get a result
that that's it you good done well a
deterministic algorithm for a private
key Cipher a symmetric Cipher is fine
it's not a problem
but think about how a deterministic
algorithm works when the key is public
an asymmetric Cipher e of M is the same
every time so an attacker who sees
Cipher text could look and say well I
wonder if that might happen to be a
cipher text of this message maybe it's a
short thing maybe
it's um just a yes or no answer to an
important question I can well I encrypt
yes I encrypt no and I see which one
matches the cipher text it's not so good
so you have to you know have some way of
of getting past this um and um there's
another and and you can guess what
what'll come here as a way of getting
past this um you know putting in some
Randomness that's that's unpredictable
so that even even encrypting the same
thing over again um will give you
different results RSA also has a a
property which can be very useful but
can be a big problem and that is it's
what's called multiplicatively
homomorphic okay a lot of math terms to
say that if this is an encryption of M1
and this is an encryption of M2 then
this product is an encryption of the
product and I'll talk more about this um
actually uh the our our final session
but um it's if you just go through the
RSA equation it's it's all very
algebraic it all just pops out yeah I
can multiply two Cipher text and this is
a cipher text of of the
product okay this actually has some
applications for legitimate use it also
has some applications for an attacker
right an attacker may be able to create
valid messages out of old ones by
combining them in in in various ways and
I'm about to show you one so RSA padding
um has was introduced as a way of
dealing with these things and basically
there's there's a whole set of standards
for use of um public key cryptography
pkcs or the public key cryptography
standards there are now about 15 of them
um introduced primarily by the RSA
company but others have been involved in
them and the very first number one was
what padding we put into RSA encryptions
and RSA signatures in order to keep
these bad things from happening so the
original padding seemed to be pretty
simple um it looked kind of like this
and I'll see say what these pieces are
first of all it started with a zero B
and that's because if
you're say you've got a 1024-bit
um modulus and you want to encrypt a
1024-bit value well if the value you're
encrypting is bigger than the the mod
the mod n then it's going to wrap bad
thing we know the modulus if it's a full
10 24 bit starts with a one the first
bit is one so if the first bite here is
zero we're just making sure that this is
going to be less than the modulus okay
good start now we put in a little one is
sort of an identifier here to say this
is supposed to be an encryption this is
two if it's supposed to be a signature
and other things might be reserved for
for for others just so that you can
check you won't confuse signatures from
encryptions now we need some Randomness
so what comes next is at least 16 bytes
that's good that that's a a lot of nice
random
um all
nonzeros okay let's excuse the
randomness a little bit to say that
nonzeros but we're going to use that
zero as a delimiter to say after the
first zero comes the
message okay this looks like a
completely reasonable padding scheme
looks at least it looked like it to the
people who did it it seems to take care
of the randomness issue now if you
encrypt a message twice the same value
here twice you use different Randomness
if somebody's trying to to figure out
whether you encrypted this they won't
know what Randomness you use so the
randomness is there
multiplicativity doesn't work so well
because you've got you if you multiply
two things of this format there's no
reason to think it would have that
format again you would think you so that
this seemed like a good solution and for
years it was accepted as such until a
fellow named Daniel blackener came
along and found that he could attack
this and um I'm not going to go into a
lot of detail on on this attack I just
want to give a sense for how it it's
done but it takes advantage of the
multiplicativity I did not say that
right
multiplicativity of
RSA um basically you've got some Target
value and this is an encryption of some
unknown thing and we're going to start
encrypting constants small constants we
encrypt two we encrypt three we encrypt
four up to some small value and try to
see what e of C * m looks like all we
have to do is encrypt this constant and
multiply it by this and we've got an
encryption of 2 *
m okay so let's go back and look at this
what black and Bacher did was he just
kept encrypting small values and
multiplying by by this so if you
multiply this by two well you still have
a zero up here and you'll probably have
02 or this might go up to 03
and that zero might get um knocked over
by something else but something
something else might become a zero it
might have more or less reasonable form
but what happens was when this got just
big enough to wrap mod
n then you again get to a point where
you have zeros at the beginning and a01
here and all you have to have here to
make this legitimate is you have to have
some zero bite after the first 16 bytes
so it could be way down in here and
there's a pretty good chance that you'll
get a zero somewhere down in here there
might be a lot of bites down in here and
it's going to be legitimate
again so he was able to find okay here's
exactly what I multiply by to get this
to be of the right format and that says
a lot about sort of what these high ORD
bits are because it tells you exactly
where you have to be and then he was
able to hone down and surprisingly
quickly decrypt the entire thing
yeah so I I can understand how how you
can make the format correct but can you
also get the message that you want well
he's not trying to get the message he's
trying to discover what this message is
so more information the first bit of
information is what's the right constant
to just get things balanced again and
that narrows things down a surprising
amount and it turns out that the that
things narrow and then he uses another
trick that I don't want to go into once
things get into a pretty small range to
converge very quickly so it turned out
that he could do this when you when you
say find out if it's a valid message you
mean he has to have an oracle that he
can ask exactly yes so the trick was um
and this is what what's known as a
padding Oracle you take this message you
multiply it by something to to reformat
it you send it off to a server somewhere
that will decrypt it and you wait and
see what it tells you you wait and see
does it
say okay what next or does it cough and
spurt and say I don't know what you're
talking about now this attack came at an
interesting time um the the historians
among you might might have heard of this
thing that that we commonly called the
browser Wars around here when when
Microsoft and Netscape were fighting for
control of the internet the browser and
Netscape Navigator was was leading there
were more people using that um Netscape
and Microsoft both suffered this
vulnerability I me both we were
implementing pkcs1 this was how things
work um but Netscape got it much worse
and the reason Netscape got it much
worse was not because of anything clever
we did it was because they were nicer
than we were when you send something Mal
formatted to them they would say oh
sorry um you know your your message is
Mal formatted you don't have a leading
zero here or you don't have a one here
or oh sorry none of the first 16 bytes
or one of something there zero somewhere
in the first 16 or there's no zero at
all would would be friendly you know do
what what you know a nice system would
do it give you some information the
Microsoft response was error cough die
this is no
good um it turns out in the security
context that's a lot better you don't
want to be giving away that information
so in the Netscape case it took
something like
40,000 hits on a server to be able to
decrypt a Target message or get a Target
value signed if if you want that and I
took about 10 times as much work on on
one of the Microsoft servers to be able
to do that so we we locked out there I'm
not going to say that we intended to be
UNC for security reasons but you know
again another little lesson of don't
give out more information than you
should here okay so I want to um start
talking more about um some some
practical matters uh in in implementing
things and where problems come up in
those matters um so the first thing I
want to talk about is um large integer
operations and how costly they are and
how we can improve them so let's start
off with addition and subtraction just
take a look at how that goes when we
have big numbers out there they're
broken up into blocks of 32 bits or 64
bits depending on what kind of machine
so we've got these blocks here and when
we do addition it's pretty
straightforward this looks just like
what you learned in elementary school
except these aren't digits anymore
they're 32-bit block say so what you do
is you take the first pair of blocks and
you add them up and you get get a result
and maybe a little remainder there and
then you add these together with the
remainder and you get the next block and
the next block and the next block and
you go through pretty straightforward
pretty quickly right
um effectively um if you want to add two
n block numbers you're going through n
separate 32-bit or 64 bit or whatever
the word size is additions okay and
subtraction is is similar you just go
through right to left and you know
everything works out fine okay what
about
multiplication well we multiply also the
same way we learned to do it in
elementary school but it's going to be a
lot slower right when we multiply we
start out with a value here and we
multiply it by each thing there and we
get this with a remainder and then we
move over to this block and multiply
this block by this block and this block
by that block and you sort of go through
that line and go through that line and
go through that line
and eventually we have it all there we
add things up and we get a result down
here so if you count now see for each of
the N blocks down here you're
multiplying it by n other blocks up
there so you now have to do N
squared small multiplications to do one
large multiplication and also you do n
additions to add those things together
that you've got okay why does any of
this matter well I'm going to talk about
how we can start optimizing some of this
in an important case because if you
remember for RSA for Diffy Helman for
lots of cryptographic applications a lot
of what we're doing is just
exponentiating our multiplications
aren't General multiplications so much
are they as they are multiply something
by
itself multiplying something by itself
can be much faster let's take a look at
why huh that Crush hatching wasn't
exceeding its boundaries before okay um
look at this multiplication here the
rightmost block here by this block here
and look at this multiplication here
this by this if these two values are the
same if we're squaring something then
this and this are the same this and this
are the same and these two
multiplications are actually exactly the
same multiplication even though they're
going to go into different places down
here so what this says and I won't
bother putting you through this you
could you know do it on your own but if
you do careful bookkeeping here that
nearly half of the small integer
multiplications can be eliminated
they're repeats and you can save a lot
of the time because you're doing a lot
of these small multiplications whenever
you do a large exponentiation say Okay
so let's look again at exactly how this
this goes so remember we would often
compute something like y to the X by
repeating squaring and the way to think
of this is we start with Y the 1 square
that square that square that square that
and multiply together the associated
values so to be very specific and
pedantic suppose in this example we want
to do x to the 26th and we write it as a
product of powers of two in the exponent
so we take
X we write it out in
binary and we take the
powers and this tells us which Powers
now now we want to keep and multiply
together to get let me leave it this for
now this so let's think about how much
work we're doing about 2third of the
multiplications that we're doing are
actually squarings right we have to
square all the way up and then of these
things that we Square to get all the way
here about half of them get multiplied
together make sense okay so this is good
because squaring is faster so so if 2/3
of the multiplications are
squarings then if we cut the time of the
squarings in half because we only have
to do this multiplication and not that
multiplication then we're cutting out a
third of the time to do one of these
exponentiations that seems really good
that's a big win this is important in
our practical considerations of how to
do RSA Diffy Helman and pretty much any
public e operation
fast but
now let me show you something oh
sorry that's right I want I I have one
more detail I want to show you about
this in
practice we typically are not going to
do all the squarings and then figure out
which things we multiply together it's
hard bookkeeping you know if you figure
this is you know a thousand bit exponent
there's a lot of big values that we have
to keep sitting around before we figure
out what to multiply normally you inter
leave and you can do it in two ways you
could do it bottom up you do you know y
to the first um and then you say okay am
I going to need one of those Y no y^ s
yes I'll need one of those and I
accumulate it into my product that's
forming on the side as I go or you can
do it top down um it's actually pretty
easy you know you start off with X to
the first Power and now you square it
you've got x squared now that's One X to
the one zero now if I want x to the one
one I multiply that by X I've got x to
the 3 now if I want now if I square that
I've got x to the
6th square that I've got x to the 12th
but oh there's a one there so I multiply
by X that's x to the 13th that's what I
want there now x square that and I've
got x to the 26 so you can do it top
down or bottom up either way works but
you're going to one way or another want
to inter leave these based on the bit
pattern okay in NE case it's you're
doing squarings and occasionally you're
doing a multiply
based on whether there's a zero or one
there half the time you do a multiply
half the time you don't do a multiply
after the squaring okay now I'm going to
show you a Power
Trace I got this off of the cryptography
research website they're a company in
San Francisco that does a lot of work on
so-called side channels information that
comes out of um crypto systems that one
might not expect and here
you just look at the power used by a
device say a smart card hook up some
probes you're not supposed to get be
able to get the key out you see okay
here are the the squares the low values
here are the high values those are the
the side
multiplies and you can very easily group
them and see you know which squares have
multiplies right after them and
basically just read off the
exponent okay you're done that's the
secret right there you've got the
key okay um there are a lot of these
side Channel attacks out there there's
this um Power analysis and this somewhat
more sophisticated form called
differential power analysis you can do
timing attacks the when when you do a
square and multiply that takes a lot
longer than doing just a square and
don't
multiply and there are some timing
attacks that can be employed um at a
distance even over a network when you
don't even have direct access to the
device and just sort of check how long
it takes to decrypt this how about that
how about that and sort of figure out
very finally exactly where the the the
changes are these are real these have
been implemented some cach attacks um
Time by by the way these attacks I I'm
applying them to RSA but they apply to
symmetric crypto systems as well um cash
attacks are this notion of it takes a a
lot longer to fetch something out of
main memory than it does out of cash so
if I running on the same machine as
you're running on I might periodically
decide to flush a cash line and see what
happens and I I can certainly do that I
can cause you know one line one it the
way cash is organized it's sort of a
thin band of cash I'm not flushing all
of cash but just flush a narrow region
of cash um by you know doing something
that's going to cause a lot of reads on
that then column and then I see oh the
thing that's sharing the machine with me
is suddenly taking a lot longer hm it's
got a lot of cash misses I guess it was
using this part of cash and that can
actually been be done the uh attacks of
this form were demonstrated on um the uh
um Amazon uh cluster um where you could
actually force your job to run be
co-hosted on the same processor as
somebody else's job and figure out their
keys now the way this was done was by
keystroke timings of typing passwords
and watching how long it was taking for
people to type passwords for instance
and and figuring out which keys they
were hitting by their time there but
this is It's legitimate it worked it
sniffed passwords that way across the
web um um there even acoustic
attacks um if you listen carefully
enough and I've heard this you can hear
the difference between a square and a
multiply you you put in microphones and
you get really close yeah you can you
can hear that um I I also um saw an
attack on a voting system a few years
ago where um you were able to quite well
hear the difference between selections
that were being made this was a a voting
system that was being used in the
Netherlands and um what happened was um
the name of the selection and most
people selected a party would be
displayed um in sort of a a dot matrix
display um and it turned out that the
technology being used to do this was
designed for English and with when there
were diacritical marks accents then it
would go and a second pass to put those
marks in and one party had an accent
somewhere in it and you could from
outside of the voting booth like 50 feet
away with a receiver Point pointed to
the thing listen and here you voting for
this beep beep beep boop you it was very
very obvious difference you could just
sit there and tell how everybody was
Voting okay yep there was a recent paper
where they figured out the password on
entered on the soft keyboard by reading
accelerometer readings of the mobile
devices accelerometer yes uh O So as you
typed in there's a specific uh so it's
because you you hit the middle of the
keyboard differently from the edges and
it causes things to bounce and torque
this is a torque based
attack very nice I like that um so the
Accel accelerometer is accessible to oh
it's accessible to other apps I guess
that are already device so the app is
just listening to the accelerometer oh
this is this is a nice attack I should
add that okay accelerometer you put that
right
there okay um so how do we mitigate some
of these attacks well
um what we typically do here as painful
as it is is try to pretend that we're
doing everything the same way
always
exactly exactly we we kill a a lot of
the
optimization um and we wind up running
slower um but in particular you know
only half the time you're doing a
multiply well don't admit that do a
multiply every time just discard it
quietly when you don't need it um so you
do this and you lose all the performance
gain you got from squaring but still you
kind of want to do that uh at least you
get the everybody knows you're going to
be squaring you don't want want to throw
away that but at least you it it comes
out as a a wash here unfortunately um
but this is sort of a
um a an admonition to why it's important
why we as a company want everybody using
a standard centralized implementation of
all our crypto
algorithms this stuff is not static most
code is in some sense static and that if
you do it you write it perfect
you can shut it up close close it up in
a vault it's done great no bugs it's
perfect with crypto code things are just
fine until somebody finds a
new uh accelerometer attack or whatever
and suddenly we have to go back to the
code and tweak it to make it as
insensitive as possible so you know
constant time constant acceleration
constant whatever so that you know it's
resistant to these things
and it's a lot more manageable to do
this in a central place where we're
hearing about the attacks we you know
the people who are sort of on the front
lines in this know okay this is a new
attack we've got to fix the code rather
than 50 different implementations of the
code throughout the company who knows
where they are the people who wrote them
have long since gone you know um not
good so keeping it centralized so that
we can maintain it is is really
important okay I'm going to tell you
about a couple of other tricks
um one that's uh I think uh particularly
clever um called
katuba um and the idea is this suppose I
want to multiply two pols let's say two
binomials ax plus b and CX plus d well
here's the
result and here are the four
coefficients that are sort of the input
you everything else is is just formal of
how we write it and we really need if we
want to compute this product three
values we need
AC we need a plus BC and we need BD okay
those are three values we need the way
we normally do this is with four
multiplications and an addition right we
multiply AC we multiply a d we multiply
BC we multiply BD and we do that
addition and we're done these additions
here aren't actually done right that's
just formal saying it's a separator from
our point of view between the X squ term
and the X term if we're just trying to
get the the polinomial here we don't
actually carry out an addition there so
the these are the steps we've done now
let me show you a different way of doing
this suppose we would do something
really strange ignore the fact that
these are
pols and a and b are coefficients of
different terms and we just add them
together a plus b and we add together C
plus d and we take the product of
those
well we can now subtract off AC and BD
and we get ad D plus BC which is our
middle term
there okay how much work did that take
turns out there are three
multiplications we have to oh well let
me start off with the additions sorry we
have this addition and that addition
those are actual additions that have to
be performed here there are three
multiplications there's this product
over here of the two additions we just
did we have to do this multiplication we
have to do this
multiplication and then when we do this
subtraction and that subtraction we've
got
that so a total of three
multiplications but more addition and
subtraction work got us the same
thing well but that's more work well not
really not if these are Big
multiplications remember these big
multiplications were N squared the
additions and subtractions were order n
so if these are really big things then
we can actually save a lot of the
compute Time by applying this trick and
then applying it recursively on smaller
and smaller values now this I've
described this for um pols it also works
on integers it's a little bit more
cumbersome okay and you lose some of the
benefits so they have to be pretty big
numbers to to get much benefit out of
this if they're small you probably don't
want to do it because um unlike pols
with integers you get
carries right the um the the product of
two terms when you're multiplying
polinomial never bleeds onto another
term somewhere but if you you know
multiply two integers block by block
then this block times this block has um
a overflow that becomes the carry onto
some other block and it makes it a
little bit Messier
but still and I'm not going to go
through this in any detail if we write
this as a * 2 to some power and C * 2 to
some power there instead of the X we get
something that looks very similar and we
can do kind of the same things and
katuba helps that a
lot okay I'm going to show one well I'll
I'll show two more major optimizations
and one which creates huge
vulnerabilities and and problems the
first is chinesee remaindering
okay um there's an wonderful
mathematical property called Chinese
remaindering probably um it's not clear
whether this is sort of insulting in the
the way it was was termed or it was
intended as a tribute but it was
discovered by unnamed ancient Chinese
mathematicians um literally Millennia
ago um and the idea is basically that if
I know know what x mod P is equal to and
I know what xod Q is equal to then I can
figure out what xod PQ is equal to okay
as long as p and Q are distinct or or
well have no common factor um is all you
need if in particular if they're
distinct primes but if they have no
common factor then you can do this um
and this is really nice in doing
computation because it's actually a
fairly simple thing to do and here's a
formula it's if not that hard you do
have to take an inverse and I haven't
told you how to take inverses mod P and
mod q but it's really not very hard to
do and if you want I sometime I can show
you how to do it um but it's a
relatively simple
formula and the idea is when you apply
it to something like
RSA we're normally doing modular
exponentiation of n bit integers to nbit
Powers so now each
multiplication required n
squared small multiplies and we do n of
those to do an
exponentiation so it's n cubed to do an
exponentiation okay so any RSA
decryption or signature looks kind of
like this takes n Cub
time now if we take advantage of Chinese
remaindering we can do two half-sized
exponentiations they each each take half
of the time sorry they're each on half
of the size and since it's cubed they
each take 1/8 of the time so now we do
that and put it together at the end and
it takes only a quarter of the time to
do this that it would have if we did it
straight it's a huge savings nobody's
going to throw away this benefit when
they've got a farm of servers that are
spending you know lots of time doing
decryptions um and say okay now we have
to you know um quadruple the number of
servers because we don't want to do
Chinese remaindering not likely to
happen so people do this all the time
and if you're doing decryption if you're
doing signing you do have P andq so you
can do this not a problem but you leave
yourself open to some attacks um and
here's one kind of attack that you might
not think of but it it's really um
potentially devastating and that is if
you're just sort of sitting around and
watching a computation being done every
now and then the device is going to make
an error there's going to be a bit flip
sometime there's going to be some sort
of an error it happens not very often
but it happens it's bad if it happens
here and the reason here is if you're
doing two separate computations the mod
Pak computation and the mod Q
computation and you get an error
cropping up it'll probably happen on one
of the two sides and not when you're
putting them together
so now I've got the mod P right and the
mod Q wrong
say and now from that I can usually
figure out what the correct answer
should have
been by some other means or by going
back raising it back to the eth power to
to to do a signature um verification or
whatnot it's usually possible to roll it
back and compare it to this is what it
would have been if we were correct so if
I compare the correct value to the
incorrect
value they are the same mod P because
the mod P computation was done correctly
but they're different mod
Q so
now their difference
is zero mod P and it's not zero mod Q so
if I take one of those gcds that I
argued earlier could be done
quickly take the difference of that with
the key PQ which I don't know p and Q I
just know the product then p is going to
pop right out because this is a multiple
of p and it's not a multiple of Q
anymore suddenly the key popped
out well okay so yeah if you sit around
and wait for a device to to flip a bit
somewhere it might reveal something how
long are you going to wait how patient
are you going to be well you don't have
to be patient you might have a smart
card that's not supposed to reveal its
key or some small dedicated device but
you know think a think a smart card
think something like a chip there are
various things you can do to a chip to
help it not be so um so accurate these
things normally have functional
operating parameters that you're
supposed to live with and they don't
work so well if they go outside of that
range like if they're given too little
power or too little voltage um to to
work with or too much power too high a
voltage cold environments warm
environments microwave
ovens this is the good attack put put a
smart card in a
microwave yeah anyway the goal here and
there are lots of these fault induction
attacks um you're trying to induce a
fault what you do is take your target
device and you put it in some sort of um
challenging environment for it and you
don't want to make it too challenging
you don't want to make it be complete
mess you just perform an RSA operation
in a challenging environment and you
tweak it a little bit so that maybe
there are one or two faults if if
there's one fault great if there are two
faults well there's a good chance they
still both occurred on the same side on
the mod P side or the mod Q side
whatever you get it to do that you
compare the actual output with what was
supposed to come out and you've got the
key you just take a gcd and you're all
done okay it's pretty serious attack um
this is you know one of the many attacks
that Xbox in particular is very
concerned about because people have
access to their devices these devices
have keys in them um many of the other
attacks apply but yeah you could run an
Xbox in a cold environment or hot
environment maybe not a microwave but
you know maybe you could you can
certainly play with the power you can do
a lot of these these things to it and
and try to get things
out okay um I'm G to talk about one more
thing here um um and that's how we do
modular reduction um I was was asked to
do this
and if you look here well let me go back
for a second um we we're Computing all
the time is a * B mod n and we've talked
about the a * b a lot we haven't talked
about the mod n right mod n is division
and take the remainder okay and now if
you think about how you do
multiplication we know how to do it you
do it the way you did it in school think
about the way you learn to do division
in school it's basically you take
numerator and take the denominator and
you kind of guess
well computers aren't very good at this
step and trying to code this up is hard
is ugly it really does not go at all
well it's much much slower to do
division it's much much worse to do
division it's hard to get this right it
really is
um yeah it's awful
um we really want to not have to do this
um do we have a choice well it turns out
there is and there's something called
the Montgomery method um invented by
Peter Montgomery who um did this before
he joined Microsoft but has
been here for uh over 15 years um and
the idea is basically you can do all
your computation in a domain where you
don't have to do this division
and then you just you work do a little
bit of work to transform yourself into
this domain where you don't have to do
the division and then a little bit of
work to get yourself out and as long as
you're doing a lot of computation in the
middle then the penalty of going in and
back is is well worth it okay so um let
me show you basically how this is done
I'm not going to go into any detail I
promise I promise um because it looks
ugly looks hard um now you can verify
all of this if you want um but the basic
idea is we get some value R which is
just one and a bunch of zeros if we've
got a a 32 byte modulus let's say m is
32 bytes long um then um then R would be
a one followed by 32 bytes of zeros if
it's a 10 24-bit modulus it's a one
followed by 1024 zeros whatever and
we're just taking that value mod modm
and we're doing some calculations with
it and you get this funny fact down here
and the funny fact is it turns out that
you can calculate a * B times the
inverse of this R I was just talking
about mod the M that you care
about fairly quickly and efficiently you
can do this at the cost of two
multiplications effectively um in
normally what we do is a multip to get a
a * B and then a division which is much
worse than a multiplication many times
worse instead it's a multiplication and
another multiplication much much better
okay so you can verify this on your own
I'm not going to push through this but
the trick is this the Montgomery product
that you can compute
efficiently is a * B remove an
R okay well can we make use of this it
turns out is a very nice trick that
allows this what we do is we take all of
our values that we're going to be
Computing on and multiply them by R to
begin with the Montgomery transform so
if we're
exponentiating it's just one value we
just multiply it by R and put it into
Montgomery
form now when we take the Montgomery
product of a * R and B * R we get two RS
in there we get this R and this R but
this Montgomery product removes an R so
now we have again an extra R so all of
our computation everything we do has
this extra R hanging around with it so
we put in an extra r at the beginning we
do all our computations in this domain
when we're done we pull out the extra R
and we're all set we've done this work
much more quickly much more
efficiently okay um I think this is
actually as as far as I wanted to do
today and it's 2:30 so it's good um so
um I had a few hidden slides just in
case and I get to skip them good um I
can talk about pairings for people who
care care about pairings a little bit
another time but um anyway next session
final session um I'm going to start
talking about some applications um zero
knowledge zero knowledge proof systems
what what they can do um apply to secret
sharing homomorphic encryption is
something you may have been hearing a
good deal about and I'm trying to
reserve a little bit of time to talk
about election protocols because there
are actually some very exciting things
happening um between this session and
the previous session I was down in
Austin um and um there's a lot of
progress there I'm very enthusiastic
about what's happening so I'll talk
about that a little bit um next time and
that's it are there any
questions yep at the beginning we were
talking about uh RSA encryption and
pkcs1 mhm I was under the impression
that people didn't really use RSA for
encryption um basically just use it for
encrypting keys they use it for
encrypting Keys um even that is a
problem ums one padding when encrypting
Keys yes definitely okay yeah you have
to because your your key could be
discovered the black and bucker attack
would will discover your key anything
whatever the message is so if the key is
smaller than the block size for RSA
people are pading it um TP a typical key
is 128 bits we consider that a strong
key for almost all purposes RSA we now
like to use a 20 48 bit RSA block so
it's usually a little tiny key down here
and a lot of padding up here um and if
that padding is done the way pkcs1
originally did it you can discover
somebody's Kate um and in not too long
um now now what's done now is a
different padding scheme which mixes
everything very thoroughly and it's got
provable properties so it's not just
here's the message here's the padding
with it's something called optimal
asymmetric encryption protocol which you
does a hash computation and a pseudo
generation and combines things you know
this scrambles it all up and and makes
it so that tweaking a bit here will
tweak everything and like I said has
provable properties okay another
question so talk about uh the
engineering processes and on crypto
teams are they any different what
is
um uh they're they're different but
they're different mostly in the sense I
think of the toolkit of things to do and
to not do is a lot larger than it it's
been um I'm not sure about really
different processes um so much we do we
have found internally that the sdl
process has been extremely helpful and
having a very clear structure about this
is the way things need to be done um is
very helpful um you you'll note that a
couple of the things I mentioned at the
beginning of the
vulnerabilities or open SSL kinds of
things I think we could make a good case
and maybe we haven't made this case well
enough that having good control over
software devel velopment is better for
security compared to the open-source
model of whoever wants to contribute
contributes and we just sort of put it
all together um I
think that that's something that you
know we could be telling
customers uh at least
trying um but you I I think you know
other than you sort of having clear
guidelines clear rules something like
the sdl is a process to
follow so a lot of these issues that you
brought up have uh the ATT the nature of
attacks have changed and the nature of
your Solutions have also changed yep so
how does somebody coming in the field or
uh like somebody taking over a new code
base uh what do they need to know like
inadvertently changing something and
regressions it's a lot like the growth
of Education in the world right you know
you you come in to a field 10 years
later there's more to
learn um but it really is almost
entirely just developing and hopefully
capturing and writing as much as
possible and being able to pass it on
you know here are both Uris and by by
formal mathematics and proof here are
the things we've learned we should do
here are the things we've learned we
shouldn't do and both of these lists
gets get longer and longer
every day it seems
sometimes yep I know you don't want to
talk about hardle but I hard okay you
mentioned it's it's not a failure the
cryp the cryptography per se but there's
been some interesting debates about the
failures of revocation
lists I wasn't planning on talking about
revocation lists they are a
nightmare okay um yeah well maybe I'll
say a couple words about certificate
revocation so I went way back in the
first session I think I talked about the
idea of a digital certificate um and a
digital certificate is basically
somebody signing an RSA key or another
key saying binding that key to an
individual or principal of some sort
this is my RSA key um if you want to
send something to me encrypted with this
key this is my RSA key if um you want to
check a signature from me this is the
key to check it against U things like
that um it was thought initially by the
way um the whole idea of a certificate
was um invented about a year or two
after RSA came out by Lauren celder who
worked worked here for many years um it
turns out that this model is not a great
model um because
Keys have lifetimes um Keys get
compromised principles go off and change
their function and no longer should have
access to things they once had access to
there are all sorts of reasons
why you don't want a certificate to be a
permanent thing so certificates usually
have expiration dates but the expiration
date might be a couple years and you
don't want to wait for the key to expire
before saying no no no I know I issued
this certificate but no no no forget
what I said um
the way that this is typically managed
is with issuers of certificates also
issues lists of of um
takebackspace the companies just say
Okay revoke these keys please and you
get massive lists of keys being revoked
um so I personally hate the whole um
model of Long Live certificates um
there's something that goes to the Other
Extreme uh called ocsp which is the
online
certificate what what status protocol I
couldn't remember that s online
certificate status protocol where you
just you know immediately you query a
trusted party and say okay you know what
what is Alice's key right now um you
know is this a good key or Alice gives
me a key and and I say is this Alice's
key and I get an immediate response I I
actually like something partway in
between um I like short lived
certificates certificates that are good
for like 24 hours um normally
certificate revocation lists come out
maybe every two weeks or so so there's a
two-e vulnerability
period there already um we can shorten
this substantially um and have things
very practical if rather than every time
I want to get Amazon's public key I have
to go through Go hidden OS ocsp server
and millions of people are doing that
every day if Amazon just once a day goes
to a server and gets a fresh key and Yep
this key is current it's within the last
24 hours that's fine um and then you
don't worry about crls they just expire
um there are there are a few choices on
how to do this but um but yes
certificate revocation lists we use them
they're are principal way of doing
things and they're becoming less and
less manageable over time more and more
of a
nightmare yeah are there better
solutions for offline scenarios like ACS
or something like that with Blu-ray
playback
um I I don't think especially if if
you're really
offline um
then you you you trust the last thing
you saw when you were online and that
that's pretty much the most you can do
and um people like to have their
certificates you know long live because
they might be offline the we we have our
our rules have you know very specific
limits on certificate lifetimes right
now I think two 2 years for most CTS I
think there are some exceptions that go
a little bit longer than that but most
that doesn't mean they're followed the
worst that I've ever seen was aert
issued by
zoon for a 200-year
lifetime which I think the the effective
date was something like
1914 I didn't know that you know people
were issuing shts then but yeah 1914
through 2114 I think was its effective
period
yeah was there good use for that or was
that just an
an I I put us in a Sweet Spot yeah right
zoon had its its day right in the middle
of that period yeah this is actually my
my wife noticed this it came to her
attention she showed it to me what um
and
yeah problem with first
starts I not figure out why and there's
nobody left for me to ask
right all right anything
else okay well have a nice couple of
weeks um let me know if there's anything
thank
you let me know if there's anything in
particular you
want